lo que vamos a hacer en este vídeo será
hablar sobre el concepto de potencia de
una prueba de significancia aunque la
idea de potencia aparece en los primeros
cursos de estadística resulta que es
algo que puede ser difícil de calcular
sin embargo es interesante saber lo que
significa y los mecanismos para aumentar
o disminuir la potencia de una prueba de
significancia vayamos al punto la
potencia es una probabilidad la podemos
considerar como la probabilidad de que
estamos haciendo lo correcto cuando la
hipótesis nula es falsa es decir la
probabilidad de rechazar la hipótesis
nula dado que es falsa así planteada la
puedes ver como una probabilidad
condicional sin embargo hay otra manera
de conceptualizar la en relación con
errores tipo 2
tenemos que esto también es igual a 1
menos la probabilidad de no rechazar la
hipótesis nula
en el caso en el que la hipótesis nula
es falsa esto que acabo de escribir no
rechazar la hipótesis nula en el caso en
el que la hipótesis nula es falsa es la
definición de error tipo 2 por lo que
podemos ver la potencia como la
probabilidad de no cometer un error tipo
2 o 1 - la probabilidad de hacer un
error tipo 2 espero que esto no te
resulte confuso déjame escribir esto
entonces es igual a la probabilidad de
no cometer un error tipo 2
así que cuáles son los aspectos que
influyen en la potencia para poder
comprender esto voy a extraer dos
distribuciones muestrales una en la que
vamos a suponer que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera y la otra en la que vamos a
suponer que la hipótesis nula es falsa
es decir que el valor real del parámetro
poblacional es distinto al establecido
en la hipótesis nula por ejemplo
supongamos que tenemos una hipótesis
nula en la cual la media poblacional es
igual a mu 1 y tenemos una hipótesis
alternativa h
que establece que la media poblacional
es diferente a mu 1
así que suponiendo que estamos en la
situación en la cual la hipótesis nula
es verdadera cuál sería la distribución
muestral recuerda lo que hacemos en
pruebas de significancia es que tenemos
una población déjame dibujarla aquí
tenemos una población nuestras hipótesis
establecen una aseveración sobre algún
parámetro de la población las cuales
probamos al tomar una muestra de cierto
y calculamos un estadístico en este caso
sería la media de nuestra muestra y
evaluamos la probabilidad de obtener
dicho estadístico suponiendo que la
hipótesis nula es verdadera si esa
probabilidad es menor que cierto umbral
llamado nivel de significancia
rechazaremos entonces la hipótesis nula
lo anterior lo podemos pensar de la
siguiente manera en caso de que la
hipótesis nula sea verdadera tendríamos
una distribución muestral que se vería
algo así la hipótesis nula es verdadera
así que en el centro de la distribución
estaría el valor de mu 1 y la forma
precisa de la distribución muestral
estará dada por el tamaño de la muestra
al incrementarse el tamaño de la muestra
esto sería más angosto al disminuir el
tamaño de la muestra esto sería más
amplio establecemos un nivel de
significancia que básicamente es la
probabilidad de rechazar una hipótesis
nula que es verdadera como ya hemos
mencionado podemos considerar el nivel
de significancia como la probabilidad de
cometer un
error tipo 1 entonces el nivel de
significancia lo podemos representar
como cierta área digamos que es esta
área que estoy sombreando en anaranjado
aquí está corresponde al nivel de
significancia así que si al tomar una
muestra y calcular su media ésta cae en
alguna de estas regiones
entonces rechazaremos la hipótesis nula
si resulta que la hipótesis nula es
verdadera estarías cometiendo un error
tipo 1 sin darte cuenta sin embargo para
la potencia nos interesa el error tipo 2
en este caso tenemos una probabilidad
condicional dado que la hipótesis nula
es falsa entonces construyamos otra
distribución muestral para en el caso en
que la hipótesis nula sea falsa voy a
extender mi eje aquí imaginemos un
escenario en el que la hipótesis nula es
falsa para el cual se cumple que la
media es mu 2 supongamos que mu 2 está
por aquí así que en este escenario la
distribución muestral podría verse así
de nueva cuenta dependiendo del tamaño
de la muestra a mayor tamaño de la
muestra esta curva de campana será más
estrecha se podría ver entonces algo así
en este caso deberíamos rechazar la
hipótesis nula pero cuáles son las
muestras en las que no vamos a rechazar
la hipótesis nula a pesar de que tenemos
que hacerlo no vamos a rechazar la
hipótesis nula si obtenemos una muestra
aquí o aquí o aquí una muestra para la
cual si se supone que la hipótesis nula
es verdadera su probabilidad no es tan
baja así que la probabilidad de cometer
un error tipo 2 cuando deberíamos
rechazar la hipótesis nula lo cual no
hacemos corresponde a esta área que
tenemos aquí y la potencia la
probabilidad de rechazar la hipótesis
nula dado que es falsa
está representada por esta distribución
en morado
eso será el resto del área que tenemos
aquí entonces cómo podemos aumentar la
potencia una manera es incrementar alfa
incrementar el nivel de significancia
recuerda que el nivel de significancia
está representado por esta área al
aumentar esta área incrementamos el
nivel de significancia lo cual resulta
en un aumento de la potencia ahora esta
región amarilla es mayor hemos movido
este límite a la izquierda te podrías
preguntar entonces si incrementar la
potencia es algo que queremos porque no
simplemente aumentamos el valor de alfa
el problema con eso déjame escribirlo
aquí si incrementas alfa eso va a
incrementar la potencia pero también
aumentará la probabilidad del error tipo
1 recuerda que esa es una manera de
concebir alfa como la probabilidad del
error tipo 1
de qué otra forma podríamos incrementar
la potencia si aumentamos el tamaño de
la muestra estas distribuciones van a
ser más angostas y como puedes ver aquí
si ambas distribuciones se hacen
angostas la situación en la cual no vas
a rechazar la hipótesis nula aunque
deberías va a corresponder a una región
con un área más pequeña otra manera de
ver esto es que va a haber menos
traslape entre estas dos distribuciones
muestrales déjame escribir lo anterior
si incrementas en el tamaño de la
muestra esto incrementará la potencia
esto en general es mejor si es que
puedes hacerlo otra situación que podría
estar o no bajo tu control es a medida
que sea menor la variabilidad de los
datos eso también va a ocasionar que
estas distribuciones muestrales sean más
angostas y eso también aumentará la
potencia así que a menor variabilidad de
los datos la cual podemos pedir con la
varianza o la desviación estándar eso va
a incrementar la potencia
la potencia también aumentará a medida
que el valor real del parámetro se aleje
del establecido en la hipótesis nula
escribamos lo valor del parámetro
alejado de la hipótesis nula lo que
establece eso también va a incrementar
la potencia estas dos últimas no están
por lo general bajo tu control pero el
tamaño de la muestra y el nivel de
significancia así lo están sin embargo
con el nivel de significancia hay un
costo si incrementamos la potencia con
esto también incrementamos la
probabilidad del error tipo 1 se da el
caso de que algunos investigadores
plantean si el error tipo 2 es más
crítico estoy dispuesto a asumir el
costo voy a aumentar el nivel de
significancia pero si el error tipo 1
resulta más crítico
entonces no usaré esta alternativa en
cualquier caso el incrementar el tamaño
de la muestra si lo puedes hacer es lo
mejor nos vemos en el próximo vídeo